placez les handicaps au coeur des
échanges et des témoignages
c'est l'action menée par les
professionnels sur ce complexe sportif à
saint-andré pendant toute une journée
les accompagnons et les personnes en
situation de handicap ont pu s'informer
sur les différents dispositifs de prise
en charge comme ici au département avec
le pass transport et le pass loisirs
alors ses côtés de ted pour les
personnes porteuses d'un handicap
donc ça permet de sentir des choses elle
pour qu'elle et activités sportives
culturelles et loisy dakar mobilité
inclusion ça à tout nouveau dispositif
du département donc c'est ça arrive au
département depuis le mois de juillet
2010 cette voie là et donc c'est une
carte qui remplace qui remplacera au fur
et à mesure les cartes de stationnement
carte d'invalidité écart de priorité
chef de file de l'action sociale
le département a pour mission d'aider et
d'accompagner les personnes porteuses de
handicap
la maison départementale des personnes
handicapées de la réunion est un outil
au coeur de ses missions parce que nous
on est là pour évaluer un petit peu la
situation globale de la personne en
situation de handicap et mettre en place
les moyens de compensation nécessaire au
domicile à l'école ou dans l'allier en
fait général l'école est également un
lieu d'inclusion pour les personnes
handicapées grâce au dispositif ulis
unité localisée pour l'inclusion
scolaire des lycéens ont participé à
cette journée
eux aussi sensibilisés au monde du
handicap
vous avez la chance pour elle je suis
autonome et il faut que l'école est là
pour vous aider nous j'espère qu'un jour
on aura une école mais éviter
chance vous avez solarisé et de mener un
projet viable à la réunion 47 1400
personnes sont reconnus comme porteuses
d'un handicap soit 6% de la population
[Musique]